wien das ist eine fahrt mit dem fiaker
vorbei an imposanten bauten aus der
österreichischen kaiser zeit
das ist ein besuch im typischen wiener
kaffeehaus oder eine vorführung der
berühmten lipizzaner in der
hofreitschule und mit dem riesenrad im
prater kann man in der gondel über der
stadt schweben auch die redaktion des
britischen lifestyle magazins monocle
und ihr chefredakteur tyler brulé sind
begeistert von der österreichischen
hauptstadt in deren ranking der
lebenswertesten städte der welt kommt
wien auf platz zwei wen ist interessant
und hat bei uns sehr gut abgeschnitten
zum einen weil die stadt wohl
proportioniert ist wenn man ein
jahrhundert zurück schaut dann hatte
wien damals sogar eine höhere
bevölkerungsanzahl als heute jetzt hat
die stadt genau die richtige größe
damit die einwohner entspannt leben und
auch mal durchatmen können
im jahr 1916 hatte die mehr als 2,2
millionen einwohner heute leben hier
rund 1,8 millionen menschen
das wird wohl zu der entspannten
atmosphäre für die die österreichische
hauptstadt berühmt ist
es gibt mehr gebäude aus der gründerzeit
als in paris budapest oder berlin
die historische altstadt zeigt immer
noch von der vergangenen pracht der k &
k monarchie und gehört zum unesco
welterbe
wien ist aber auch eine stadt der
kontraste
ihr wahrzeichen der gotischen
stephansdom spiegelt sich in 1990 fertig
gestellten hollein aus
ein anderes beispiel für
unterschiedliche baustile das
hundertwasserhaus aber nicht nur die
architektur vielfalt zählte beim
städteranking ein hauptpunkt bei der
beurteilung der städte war dieses jahr
das bewusstsein für mobilität wien
überzeugte mit seiner infrastruktur in
der innenstadt ist alles zu fuß
erreichbar
einer der punkte warum wien laut monokel
die zweit lebenswerteste stadt zur
weltweit ist
es gibt noch viele andere gründe die für
ihn sprechen
ich denke da an die kulturellen
einrichtungen es gibt hervorragende
galerien und museen
manche leute sagen dass sich die ganze
stadt wie ein museum anfühlt und das
klingt etwas abfällig
aber ich finde gerade das sollte man
feiern mit mehr als 100 museen bietet
wien eine große bandbreite für kunst
interessiert ob malerei skulpturen
grafiken architektur oder moderne kunst
im schloss bellevue die ehre gibt es die
weltweit größte sammlung von gustav
klimt gemälde die werke des
österreichischen jugendstil künstlers
sind weltberühmt wie der kuss
[Musik]
im palais liechtenstein sind gegenstände
aus dem besitz der fürstenfamilie
liechtenstein ausgestellt es ist eine
der bedeutendsten privatsammlungen der
welt
[Musik]
komponisten wie mozart beethoven
schubert oder strauß haben hier gewirkt
die staatsoper wien ist eine der ersten
adressen für klassische musik und die
stadt hat noch mehr zu bieten
vienna in wien sind auch das nachtleben
und die gastronomie ausgezeichnet denn
hier die das leben auch nachts weiter in
vielen clubs und bars und auch dem
einheimischen gefällt ihre stadt
ist eine übersichtliche start ist eine
stadt mit geschichten und geschichte
schon viele seen viel erleben
man spürt die kreativität man spürt dass
kunst und musik und tanz einfach schon
ein elementares ja ein teil der stadt
cent wert ist eine sehr langsame stadt
eine stadt die die diese notwendige
entschleunigung wirklich lebt
entschleunigung wird auch in den
traditionellen wiener kaffeehäusern
gelebt sie sind eine institution und die
öffnungszeiten von frühmorgens bis
spätabends sieben tage die woche sind
erstaunlich im gegensatz zu den
geschäften in wien
hier herrscht noch eine strikte
ladenöffnungszeit und am sonntag bleiben
sie komplett geschlossen das ist eine
der wenigen punkte wie monokel an wien
kritisiert das magazin wünscht sich für
die zukunft einkaufen auch am sonntag
dann wäre wien als lebenswerteste stadt
europas
unschlagbar
[Musik]